for decades we've been promised flying
cars for decades we've been disappointed
but it looks like we're getting close a
new company called Ikon is selling a
little airplane that's part flying car
and part flying boat I got to try it out
in New York City that's where I work can
I get out of here before you would the
icon a5 is a light-sport aircraft a
newer type of weekend fun play icon is
taking advantage of recent regulations
in aviation which have opened up
airspace for recreational flight in
short Ikon has built what is as close as
we've come to an honest-to-goodness on
the market flying car granted it's a
flying car that costs around $200,000
but still the vision here is long-term
is to democratize aviation and that
that's been set in motion by the FAA
regulation change so the eff may
recognize that the personal flying
market should be much more accessible in
2004 the FAA created the sport pilot
license which means you only need 20
hours of flight time to start flying
your very own sports aircraft I didn't
have time to get a license but Icahn
took me up for a ride and even let me
steer a little I try to land on that
barge I hit the flight admit controls
were surprisingly smooth at one point
the pilot stalled the plane to show off
the a fives spin resistant design rather
than plummeting into a nosedive the
plane just sort of floated in midair
small plans are nothing new but one of
ikon selling points is at the a5s wings
fold transformer style for storage and
transportation it's about 8 feet tall
with the wings folded so one thing we
didn't get to see today this thing folds
up right I mean it's it's depending on
the size of your garage it's probably
the length of it is
like a short short school bus kind of
went there like a conversion van think
like a ski boat okay got it towed ski
boat the legs yeah felt that sighs when
it's folded up got it so unless you
happen to have a huge garage it may be
hard to store this craft at home and
while it can run on easy to find
high-octane automotive gas it can only
fly 300 miles on a tank but if you've
got 200 grand to blow that sports
license and the storage space you may be
able to finally fulfill your dream of
flying